I'm reading a pretty cool bug it's a
grant cardone H I'm listening to on on
Amazon books whoever it is it's Quan
cardones
I think it's going to survival yeah yeah
yeah great really good really good
because in life I think everything sells
mm-hmm so you need to learn how to sell
even if it's not just a product it might
be yeah but it might be selling your
yourself to someone as a brand you know
selling your idea to someone you send an
opportunity anything so we just lost I'd
read a map because everything sells okay
everything and everything is people
property businesses are people business
yeah you don't get paid from property
you get paid from people that might live
in the property or buy the property but
if you don't know how to communicate
with people then then you're not gonna
get money you know that your
communication you can be a good
communicator you could be good at sales
what do you think maybe the top three
skills and assets someone should have
great question I think deal analysis is
really good like being able to analyze a
deal yeah and work out the numbers it's
a skill that I had to learn and I think
that's just basic maths so for instance
in property what's the rent
what's the value what's the return on
investment gonna be you know what's the
risk what's that all that deal analysis
stuffs really and I would have really
struggled with that yeah but we've like
the academy training stuff that just
makes it that part whole lot easier
because it's actually simple yeah it's
very very simple you just have to know
what you're doing yeah you do you just
have to do the formulas and knowing the
formulas yeah and everything I teach is
all about formulas anyway so knowing the
formulas I think that's a skill yeah
secondly would be I would say just more
rather than a skill more of an attitude
I think having it having an attitude of
gratitude okay like where you just are
grateful and thankful yeah I think that
will serve you so well because I mean
I'm you know I run a company with 42 42
people in it across the across the
boards and the companies if I think if I
was like and entitled you don't want any
tired employees but you also don't want
an entitled man
yeah and I think if you're like entitled
and not grateful you just people are
gonna resent you yeah or resent you it's
a really bad thing no even tenants you
don't want tenants to think that you're
a greedy landlord and just the smallest
things like just sending a Christmas
card and saying I appreciate you as a
tenant you know give us a shout if it
you guys in my way costs a pound and you
can systemize it and you mean it but
having the heart that what is just
grateful for for your staff and for your
tenants and for your colleagues and for
your trainers
same with trainers like people that mint
have mentored me like salmon sushi for
instance he sort of started me off in
property he didn't do loads in terms of
like you know like but but but what he
did do made made it in his mind it
didn't it wasn't a lot but it makes a
lot to me yeah and if it wasn't for his
you know those few phone calls and
things that he helped me with in ideas
and those presentations I heard you know
so now even today even though like 10 12
years later I'll still be grateful I'll
still honor him and people that have
anyone that's mentored me or helped me
whether it be family friends mentors
trainers you know always all of them be
grateful for them and I think it goes a
long way and now when I've got students
the students that honor me let's say
let's say I'll help someone and then I
see them just do a post of recognition
and stuff like that and they honor me
and they're grateful for me it makes me
want to do more you know I'm thinking oh
man how can I go the extra and I think
in that spirit of gratitude and honor
and recognition I think he's just so so
powerful and ultimately even selfishly
speaking because you give but they're
not selfish to speak in the people that
give more get more yeah and that's just
that's just I've in his different ways
of looking at like gratitude because I
also know cuz I studied a lot of Tony
Robbins yeah and he always says the
reason why the first thing he does in
the morning is he does is Prime in and
part of the prime in is thinking of
three things you're grateful for and be
and you truly get in the present mode
and you feel grateful for them things
and it sets you up for the day and I was
wondering when I was looking here why
weren't being grateful first me in the
morning set you up for the day because
being grateful for these free things
take
five minutes and then you've got the
rest of the day but this is the thing
you can't be grateful and sad at the
same time so if you live in a in a in a
world where you're constantly grateful
you can't be sad because it's completely
opposite and you can't feel two things
that want to put two emotions at once so
true so living in a world where you're
grateful all the time it will eliminate
the sadness okay and people that are
ungrateful and all you know that's what
I see people you know on social media or
whatever in that in their net complain
and all that [ __ ] and I actually feel a
bit I almost feel sad because because I
know if people are that well they're sad
people you know you know I totally agree
so that's definitely a big for me that's
like really important being grateful and
and and and just having the good
attitude yeah a really long way and then
thirdly because you asked me three
things I would say he's been able to
negotiate a deal you know yeah yeah
what's a negotiate a deal but if here's
the thing if you combine those three
skills boom here's why you negotiate a
good deal your Harden negotiate you know
how to negotiate you know the scripts
not to say but you do it from a position
of actually also wanting to help to the
person having a good attitude and we've
known your numbers yeah you just can't
not have a massive business when you do
those two things so would you relate all
of them free obviously related all of
them free things to property yeah so to
be since everything just in life there's
a free things in lovely hive need
marriage having a business staff
landlord whatever you need to be
grateful and have a good attitude you
need to be able to crunch numbers in the
deal hmm and you need to be able to
negotiate even even with family you need
to negotiate I wanna go show it my to
your girl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]